This is my cell phone, okay?
Does that look like that is the cell phone
case of a liberal?
My dad is a retired baptist minister.
He told me that in order to get people to
hear your message, you have to get them in
the church.
That is a mistake that a lot of environmentalists
make when talking to Republicans and conservatives
about solar, about clean energy.
They lead off with climate change.
That is the wrong message.
If you deliver the message of energy freedom,
energy choice, competition, national security,
innovation —
all of the sudden you have a receptive audience
and they will listen to you.
If you lead off with climate change, they're
not going to pay a bit of attention to anything
else you say.
They've been brainwashed for decades into
believing we're not damaging the environment.
Unfortunately, a lot of these fossil fuel
interests and giant monopolies have been telling
activists for decades that we're not damaging
the environment…
Everyone agrees that burning fossil fuels
releases carbon dioxide, and that such concentrations
in the atmosphere are rising.
But it’s a long and dangerous leap to conclude
that we should therefore cut fossil fuel use.
You have industries that have a lot of money
in deep pockets and they're willing to use
that money to put out negative facts and bogus
studies to convince us that renewables are
bad.
Get the facts about these out-of-state solar
companies at AZSolarFacts.com
And by God, they are not going to get away
with it.
You have to understand one thing: The Republican
party has always been, in the past, a party
of conservation.
Richard Nixon, a Republican president, actually
created the EPA to make sure we had clean
air and clean water.
Each of us all across this great land has
a stake in maintaining and improving environmental
quality.
Ronald Reagan is not actually known as an
environmental president.
But he was a conservationist.
He actually believed man was damaging the
environment and he advocated very strongly
for and signed the Montreal Protocol that
banned fluorocarbons.
If Ronald Reagan were alive today and he wanted
to ban aerosols, fluorocarbons, because he
saw scientific evidence that they were damaging
the environment, some of these same groups
that are attacking renewables would be attacking
the conservative icon Ronald Reagan.
One of the reasons I’m fighting very hard
to bring conservatives on board and to educate
conservatives to advance renewables: Failure
is not an option.
This earth is not a Republican earth.
It’s not a Democrat earth.
This earth belongs to all of us.
If you think fossil fuel is not damaging the
environment, pull your car in a garage, start
up your engine and inhale the exhaust fumes
for a few minutes and see what happens.